breaking news just in the last hour
Christine blase Ford's attorney making
an eleventh-hour desperation play with a
Senate Judiciary Committee
just moments ago she asked for yet
another day for dr. Ford to consider the
committee's offer for her to testify
this coming Wednesday the response
coming in just before 10:00 p.m. Eastern
deadline tonight joining us now with
reaction is john yoo former general
counsel to the Senate Judiciary
Committee former US Attorney David Katz
is with us along with former federal
prosecutor John Lauro
let's start with John Lauro John for a
lot of us who've been watching this over
the last few days we've been concerned
about moving the goalposts
yes I believe the the the testimony was
supposed to be on Monday not Wednesday
but so it's she was supposed to respond
about appearing on Monday I think
they're negotiating about Wednesday but
nevertheless the goalposts keep moving
it's a smart lawyer
I think representing this accuser
because she's pushing it into the last
minute to get her client as much time
leeway as she can but at what point does
the committee's patience run thin here I
think they're just about there she has
to either put up or shut up how much
preparation time does she need to tell
the truth that's the question I mean
she's been dealing with lawyers for
weeks if not months now it's time for
her to face the music she's made a very
serious accusation and it's now now the
moment of truth comes she has to face
questioning she has to be asked the
tough questions and she can't escape it
if she refuses to testify then the
bottom line is that he's going to be
confirmed and this thing is over but
there's a legal expression for what her
lawyer is doing and that's jerking
around you know she every time they
reach a point where there's an agreement
then all of a sudden you know the as you
say the goalposts move and that's just
inappropriate David I know there are
very strong feelings about this case on
both sides or you know a lot of
Democrats think that she wouldn't come
forward unless this happened
and even though she does remember key
details that's okay if this has to go on
another two or three weeks so be it but
it's interesting to note how this is
proceeding as a legal matter at the same
time because even though it's not a
legal setting a courtroom one would
think that making a demand that you have
to speak after Brett Kavanaugh is a
little rich don't you think at this
point since she's the one making the
accusation well it's not a court of law
but it certainly makes sense that the
accusation has to come first and that
the person being accused gets to hear
exactly what the accusation is and then
respond to it some of her other demands
I do think makes some sense that you
know not having all these cameras not
having all of these things that you know
high officials are used to but she's not
used to that and she's just going to
tell her side of the story and I kind of
agree with I guess it's Kellyanne Conway
who said that you know she should be
accommodated and giving her one more day
is accommodating her she shouldn't be
attacked and I think Republicans would
have a Pyrrhic victory wouldn't they if
they ended up losing the House and
Senate because they mistreated her
instead of giving her one more day and
hearing every one side of the story of
course I think they should also hear
mark judges side of the story because
you know when you're a prosecutor as I
was you always say
you know there's one more witness they
could have called why didn't they call
him the defense has the power of
subpoena let them call mark judge if
Mark judge is so important but you know
here the Democrats don't have the power
to call mark judge don't have the power
to call David that's not true what the
Democrats could have done which that in
John you you can react to this the
Democrats could have done they could
have gone out and done their own
investigation they could have
interviewed mark judge they could have
interviewed Patrick Smith they could
have done and they could have gotten
actually quite a bit done in the last 72
96 hours or so but instead what the
Democrats are doing is it going on TV
talking about how Cavanaugh is a sexual
predator someone I've known for no 28
years or so John I know you've known him
for a long time your reaction to this
latest demand by the accusers legal team
Laure you actually put your finger on it
when you said this isn't actually a
courtroom this is not a criminal trial
this is the Senate performing its
constitutional job to give advice and
consent it is a political process and a
legal process but it's not a criminal
trial the Senate doesn't need the FBI to
conduct a criminal investigation as you
say lawyer each side has committee staff
they can go out and interview people
they can interview them under oath I
think that's the most important thing
that has to happen is the stories have
to be gotten under oath under pain of
perjury from both judge Kavanaugh and
from dr. Ford the timing is actually
important the sooner the better because
as time goes on people could adjust
their stories and change them in
response to what they're hearing in the
public I'm worried about that I think
actually the committee is right to try
to freeze the stories in place as soon
as possible so that people can't start
changing their stories that would be
even worse than moving the goalposts is
that right well the Republicans did get
both judge and Patricks might they did
interview them and they did sign
declarations which were signed under
penalty of felony correct I mean so that
was done Democrats could have taken part
in the questioning they decided not to
and going back to what David Katz said
you got to be more accommodating to the
accuser I think the president was right
let her speak but to say that this the
Senate wasn't accommodating it they
could have interviewed her at home in
California they said they would they
they Grassley said he would do it behind
closed doors in public would be
questioned by an outside counsel which I
thought because it's all these white men
up there it would have been better to
have an outside counsel especially a
woman ask the questions now they don't
want that so it seems like they've been
quite accommodating except on well we're
not going to do it whenever you want to
do it because you don't get to dictate
the terms
let's John I want you to listen in all
of you to part of the letter that was
released again just about an hour ago
from the Cavanaugh accusers attorney the
imposition of aggressive and artificial
deadlines regarding the dates and
condition of any hearing has created
trim
and unwarranted anxiety and stress on
dr. Ford your cavalier treatment of a
sexual assault survivor who has been
doing her best to cooperate with the
committee is completely inappropriate
John Lauro cavalier treatment of a
sexual assault survivor seems more to me
like a political statement than it does
to be from a lawyer who wants to
actually make some headway in these
negotiations it's all about politics if
she was serious about having her client
testify she would have made that
decision certainly by now to put her
before the public let me just say one
thing she is going to be treated with
kid gloves under no circumstances is she
going to be abused or treated
disrespectfully that would be
counterintuitive to what the Republican
majority wants to do so the reality is
they've bent over backwards to have her
come in under appropriate circumstances
let's remember one thing an accuser does
not get to call the shots this is a
process with deadlines she's decided to
come forward and now she has to testify
truthfully and honestly and face the
music David well I was a prosecutor I've
also defended people in the same
situation as Judge Cavanaugh who are
faced with charges that seem absolutely
unbelievable
and they're totally denied by my clients
and I've gotten not guilty's and there
are rules of procedure in court the
rules are less clear in the Senate my
point is that the Republicans and the
committee should not be seen as not
giving her a fair shot as not hearing
her story as not understanding that
there's a very unreported crime as
Senator Collins has pointed out and
president Trump should treat her with
respect at all times including in his
tweets and the Republicans for their own
sakes should treat her with respect and
all the women in this situation a man in
this situation they don't come forward
all the time sometimes it's a long time
before they make these allegations
everybody can understand that and as I
say it's a Pyrrhic victory if they lose
the house in the Senate by mistreating
her or being cavity
don't think she's asked for so much
being cure I don't think she's asked for
so much she's asked for one more day
David the vote was she's asked her one
more day yesterday the vote was supposed
to be yesterday Feinstein John you had
the letter in July the Democrats Seidman
Randy sighed when I think it was already
plotting about how to derail Cavanaugh
the same person who's now advising the
legal team on overall you know process
and PR this has turned into a political
cudgel to be used both against Cavanaugh
the Republicans Donald Trump all the way
to the midterm elections that might
sound silly but I've been in Washington
for 30 years and it's at brick Cavanaugh
is getting no respect in my view in this
process he's not being respected too
well himself John Laura I agree with you
not only do we show respect to dr. Ford
we also have to show respect not just a
judge Cavanaugh we have to show respect
for the Senate what's going on here I
think is that the Senate has been
manipulated that these charges were held
back until the very last minute even
after the hearings are over and so what
the Senate has to do is make sure it
does its constitutional job this is not
about a forum for airing grievances the
Senate has to find out the truth there's
no forensic evidence anymore the only
thing that's left is the witness
testimony the Senators have to put them
under oath and while being respectful we
have found in our legal system the best
way to get the truth is the subject both
witnesses to questioning and
cross-examination I don't think that
anyone should be treated with kid gloves
are treated differently we ask this
people in cases every day in court rooms
around the country in these kinds of
cases I don't think we should expect any
less and give respect to Cavanaugh and
to dr. Ford but show them respect by
expecting them to tell the truth under
oath and be subject and willing to
answer questions and cross-examination
right and we don't change the cameras or
the lighting I mean this is the only one
camera angle what is that I mean if
you're gonna if you're gonna launch that
kind of allegation against someone this
late in the game 36 years later then
come along and say oh no but I don't
want to
camera and a gorilla in a and a woman
can't ask the question to me that's just
Michelle of any of that Laura we show
these for victims to respect alleged
victim okay guys all right yeah I'm
sorry I'm going on but when I heard the
camera thing I'm sorry you know
everybody who goes up before that
committee and the Senate agreed to that
Laura yeah Laura the Senate agreed to
that did I did I say they didn't I
thought it was really really goofy okay
if we you look silly and goofy
it sets a terrible precedent I don't I
don't like that precedent of having to
change the process she's absolutely in
the game a lot of a lot of us aren't
used to this because it's so late in the
game